[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in tom pelicero tom thanks
for being patient uh let me ask you the
question that we've been uh mulling over
you can have any player in the history
of the sport to start your team with
non-quarterback
and i'm getting them at the start of
their careers like draft eligible
they're 21 years old yeah
it's pretty hard to go against lawrence
taylor in a discussion like that i'll
default to the wisdom of bill belichick
and say there's not been many better
players than that in nfl history
yeah we brought up reggie white like i'm
getting longevity if i factor that in
i'm getting twice the the career at
least length with reggie white so i see
what paulie said where i'm getting a guy
who's defensive player of the year 27
and 37. jerry rice would also be in
there as well because i'm getting
longevity as well but
uh having seen lawrence taylor up close
and personal when he came into the
league i couldn't imagine being a
quarterback i mean i saw him a
pre-season game tom against the jets and
ken o'brien
i felt he was playing like it was the
super bowl i felt bad for ken o'brien i
could actually see fear in the face of a
football player
i was born in 1981 so i don't obviously
remember the early stages of lawrence
taylor's career but i do remember even
later in his career when you know there
was a lot of different stuff going on
with him he was still a fearsome player
and again haven't just listened to bill
belichick talked many times about him
and just
the attitude and the physicality and you
know the athletic ability that he
brought to the field and then you just
go you watch the old highlight clips
yeah and it's like he's he's from a
different planet in those you know he's
got the enormous shoulder pads that i
think makes everybody look smaller yet
somehow he looks like this enormous
figure who just kind of engulfs these
quarterbacks but also he changed
if you look at um you know offenses a
defensive player changed offenses
and how they blocked him so you'd have
the tight end and the tackles stay in
you know joe gibbs did that with
washington i don't know how many other
football players where you know the
offenses had to change their philosophy
just to stop a defensive player
um you know lawrence taylor stands out
to me obviously um
maybe dion with what he did how he did
it taken away half the field but can you
think of another defensive player that
offenses had to try to figure out how to
stop
well thrown away from from dion i mean
that was a big piece of it um you know
flipping over to the offensive side of
the ball defenses had to change for
randy moss i mean the year in 1999 i
believe the packers used their first
three picks on cornerbacks just to try
to figure out what they were going to do
with them now he was very much a
straight line speed type of guy where he
just but he could get over the top he
could win 50 50 balls he could beat you
down the field you get the ball in his
hands and he could do some you know
freaky stuff you think back to his punt
return days and the other things he
could do i mean he was a a rare rare
athlete and you know classic example of
that process he slid in the draft for a
variety of reasons everybody even though
everyone knew that he was a absolutely
hellacious player um but if you know if
you're talking about starting your
franchise with somebody well randy
played for a few franchises and there
were reasons behind that but you talk
about you know reggie white 10 years
apart being the defensive player of the
year randy moss had two of the greatest
seasons we ever saw in 1998 and 2007
after a venture to uh the raiders for a
couple of seasons uh they're in between
i mean i've never seen a better rookie
receiver in my lifetime than moss and
i'm not sure i've ever seen a player
have a better season than he did
when he joined up with tom brady you
know seven nfl network's coverage of the
draft from vegas kicks off thursday at
eight eastern with the first round
where's the drama in the draft tom
everywhere
that's the simplest way to to put it
right now i know that you don't have
the clear-cut number one quarterback you
don't have the sexy skill position guys
who are going to get drafted really high
you've got some really you know good
solid players up at the top of the draft
guys like aidan hutchinson highly
productive um all signs point to him
having a really long and good career
but the fact that we're sitting here
talking about a guy in trayvon walker
who granted has unbelievable traits
but had i believe nine sacks in his
entire college career at georgia being
the number one overall pick that's just
that's indicative of just kind of the
uncertainty that you have in this draft
uh a lot of that is driven by the
quarterbacks there's uh and just talking
to all the gm's and head coaches i have
over the past 48 to 72 hours here
everybody's trying to figure out at what
point uh the quarterbacks begin to go
that is absolutely going to be some of
the driving drama certainly in our nfl
network coverage as much as you never
want to knock the the offensive lineman
you know the fact that you could have
three or four offensive tackles in the
top 10 is not exactly going to be you
know the peak of excitement but
you know when does malik willis go when
does kenny pick it go uh when does
desmond ritter go these guys sam howell
they're ranked in all different ways
across different boards i had a phone
call last night with a head coach who
told me
he thought desmond ritter is going to be
the best one of out of all these guys
which you haven't heard anywhere because
everyone's talking about willis or
pickett as the top quarterback there's
just there's so much uh you know opinion
that goes into this and different teams
of different ways of evaluating things i
think there's drama all over the place
it just might not feel like going into
the draft you have the same drama
because we don't know that there's one
two three quarterbacks that are
definitely going to go in the top five
all right we have a bet here in house
that my producer paulie thinks a
quarterback will go in the top 13 picks
that's a pretty good over under if we're
if we're setting such things
here in vegas
you know the hot spots would seem to be
you've got carolina and atlanta at six
and eight respectively both those teams
are threats to take a quarterback that
seems rich for both teams to take a
quarterback but you heard scott fitter
the panthers gm saying yesterday that
the sweet spot for a trade down would be
somewhere in the teens well where do the
other threats lie you've got the saints
who own 16 and 19 you've got the
steelers who own 20. if you're a team
that's going to trade down and still try
to get a quarterback you're not going to
want to drop below those picks and if
you're a team that's trying to come up
you're probably thinking you've got to
get ahead of certainly pittsburgh
but also new orleans as well and that's
kind of the the gamesmanship that goes
into this and it's why you know right
now you know sometimes there's reports
about this team's getting calls or
making calls about trading down well
odds are they're also making trades
about their calls about trading back
they're having conversations with all
these different teams to figure out okay
what would the price be if we did this
and because again you have so much less
certainty at the top of the draft there
are way more scenarios that these gm's
are having to talk through just because
if it comes to you on the clock you've
got to be prepared to take a player but
you've also got to be prepared for a lot
of different scenarios that can play out
based upon what's happening in the
future ahead of you okay i want you on
record the quarterback and the team
who takes the first quarterback
the team is a difficult one dan and
predictions are a dangerous aspect of
the business if you are
saying the safe pick how about this the
safe bet
is going to be
that the
new orleans saints with one of their two
picks at 16 or 19 take a quarterback
okay that's not to say that they will
i'm not reporting that they will before
anybody tweets that what i'm saying is
i think a lot of people focus on the
steelers but don't overlook the saints
they did a ton of work on all these
quarterbacks uh they had private visits
uh with a bunch of them they're in a
position where they brought back jameis
winston he's making you know decent
money i wanna say it's 14 million
dollars a year uh base but it's
certainly not top of the echelon starter
money and you're starting over with the
new head coach in dennis allen so it
would make sense uh if i were betting
for you know any team let's take new
orleans out of it for a second if i had
to pick one quarterback to go first i
would say based on all my conversations
the best bet is malik willis from
liberty simply because there are a bunch
of coaches who have said similar things
to me which is he's the only guy who has
those elite traits this is a patrick
mahomes
josh allen world you can watch kenny
pickett he's running a pro style offense
he's making every throw you want to see
had a great final year at pitt where he
was for you know six years he started
like 50 games there but broke out last
season um you know a little bit like joe
burrow in that he doesn't have the elite
arm
but he's accurate enough he's got really
good leadership traits smallish hands
uh but it's where's the upside with
kenny pickett with link willis the floor
is much lower than it is on picket but
willis won over a lot of people through
obviously his workouts he's got a cannon
arm really good running ability innate
play-making ability he watched his
highlight tape it's unbelievable some of
the throws he makes but he's coming from
a super simplistic offense at liberty
much like what sam howell ran much like
what matt corral ran uh is he going to
be able to make his game translate over
and when he played you know legit
opponents like top 25 type of opponents
he had two games against him ole miss
and coastal carolina i think were the
two that beat coastal they lost to ole
miss but malik willis had like no
touchdowns and five interceptions in
those two games ran for five touchdowns
but those are all things you're taking
into account here you're projecting the
traits the traits are there he's shorter
but the traits are strong you're just
wondering can he make the leap and where
he impressed people in his interviews
was both on the board and in his
personality guys people kind of think
much like trey lands a year ago they
think this guy can do it you're betting
on the person as much as you are the
player i'll leave you with this
uh who has a new team first debo samuel
or baker mayfield
the smart money there would be on baker
mayfield and sorry for all these
gambling puns i'm really not trying to
do it i think it seeped into my veins
after several days here at the
cosmopolitan uh the smart money would be
on baker mayfield just because everyone
knows that the browns you know are in a
position where they probably have to
deal them you never say never about them
holding on to them into camp or even
having them start the season depending
what happens with desean watson whether
there potentially could be an nfl
suspension that investigation is ongoing
but they're going to get calls probably
most likely after round one when people
see where those top quarterbacks ended
up going so baker mayfield could be
something it could happen before the
draft two but most likely friday is when
the leverage points are going to line up
for potential trade with debo samuel
they're absolutely your teams interested
i can tell you there's multiple offers
that have been made
the people in the league who know kyle
shanahan best do not believe he's going
to trade this guy kyle doesn't want
players to be calling their shots debo
is also somebody who he's told his own
team kyle has told his own players in
the past this guy is probably the best
player i've ever been around and he can
do so many different things in that
offense
an offense that really revolves around
being able to run the same plays over
and over out of a lot of different
personnel groups that's why kyle use
check's so valuable to us why diva is so
valuable to him he doesn't want to let
the guy go
but they're going to have to make a
determination sooner than later and most
likely it'd have to be today just
because then you need to work out the
contract the compensation ideally you'd
physical him before the draft begins
tomorrow to finish off the trade as well
because you're going to be talking about
a first round pick and more being
involved in that trade it's going to
have to get moving if it happens i'm not
saying it won't i would just tell you
the people who have talked to kyle the
people who know how he and john lynch
think are skeptical that he's actually
going to let the guy go thank you buddy
have a good time tom we'll be watching
any time dan thanks that's tom pelicero
he's a reporter for the nfl network and
you can watch the coverage on the nfl
network
it's eight eastern tomorrow night first
round